the final trailer for Attack on Titan
part 3 is here and holy crap it looks
amazing for me personally my favorite
part was the Beast Titan making a return
as he threw these rocks at the upcoming
ships and if you slow it down you can
see that here he generated them in the
same way the Warhammer Titan would
generate its weapons this is something
we've never seen the Beast Titan do
before and some other epic moments from
the trailer include Reiner's
transformation this epic shot of the
fighting Titan and Levi just Levi if you
want a full breakdown of the final
episode when it comes out then don't
forget to click the link down below to
subscribe to the channel and until then
peace out